we are back with a fox news alert the
u.s military killing an isis-k planner
near the afghanistan pakistan border we
are just learning new details a u.s
reaper drone flew to afghanistan from a
base in the middle east to kill the
isis-k planner who was plotting they say
quote future attacks on u.s forces in
kabul a u.s official tells fox news we
will keep you updated throughout the
hour as the situation develops joining
me now is south carolina congressman
ralph norman and maryland congressman
andy harris who's a former navy reserve
medical officer gentlemen both thank you
so much for being here congressman
harris i'll start with you your reaction
uh to this killing of an isis k fighter
tonight and where it puts us in
afghanistan
well it's just too little too late the
fact of the matter is this operation has
been bungled uh this this won't retrieve
won't retrieve that bungling uh look
we've still got a lot of americans on
the ground a lot of our allies on the
ground i don't see any way we can be out
by august 31st and i think the president
has to extend that deadline given what's
happened over the last few days so you
think representative harris real quick
you think he can't even meet the august
31st deadline you're anticipating that
logistically speaking getting all u.s
troops out by then just isn't going to
happen
that's right you know we still have to
get hundreds if not thousands of
americans out we have to get our allies
out uh those who hold uh special
immigrant visas uh and their families
and then we have to evacuate five
thousand troops and equipment that's
that's a tall order for four days
sure is uh representative norman your
take on this strike first tonight
well pete look look at the look at
what's happened you know we've got 13
americans dead 20 injured
you know this administration is is a
toothless tiger i mean they don't trust
him uh if this were donald trump the
fury the the pure might
of the
the
the military would be on the taliban it
wouldn't even be a question bride has
set arbitrary dates with no plan in
place and as a result we have dead
americans got 5 000 that are left there
and one drone strike killing you know
one uh one isis member i mean really
it's an embarrassment and i don't see
anything coming of it because look at
his action look at his record and that's
why we're trying to hold blinking and
others accountable because i don't know
who he's taking advice from and whatever
advice it is
it's not good well that's what we booked
you to talk about tonight representative
norman first and foremost was the idea
that both of you representative norman
and harris are introducing articles of
impeachment
for secretary of state blinken if i may
uh representative norman why st why
state first why blink and why do you
view that's the place uh where where
accountability should start
he's secretary of state on january 26 he
took another to defend the constitution
and protect the american people he's
failed in every respect the problem he
has there's a timeline of events that
took place
uh starting with biden started giving
dates starting when the embassy
was evacuated 3 000 people on april 27th
on may 15th he got a memo that it was
dangerous over there and to keep get
americans out
bagram on july 2nd which failed we gave
up opened the prisons up to some of the
most dangerous terrorists
along with all of our equipment and it's
just been a disaster
from day one and he doesn't look at what
mike pompeo did
for the years he was secretary of state
he gave briefings
and he had an action plan blinking
simply in his role has failed and that's
why the disaster is there and whether by
listening to him listens to him or not
he should resign and that's why dr
harris and i are going to impeach him
and let's put it to a vote and see what
happens
do you think you'll get traction on this
representative harris and do you think
it should stop at state or are there
other officials you you would look for
accountability for as well
well first of all there are very few
things that we do on a bipartisan basis
in washington but but we on a bipartisan
basis agree that this was entirely
botched that this withdrawal is a
catastrophe and most americans don't
realize this was not a department of
defense effort the department of state
was running this withdrawal they were
the ones who didn't know where our
americans were they were the ones who
didn't have plans to evacuate everyone
they were the ones who allowed the
military some of the military to leave
before we evacuated our americans this
the first and foremost falls squarely on
the secretary who headed the department
that was in charge of this withdrawal
gentlemen thank you very much please do
keep us updated on this effort we
appreciate your time thank you thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else